all right uh let's shift topics now uh
on something that will likely be on the
minds of leaders across the globe the
biggest risks our world is facing in
2023. we're sharing a new list from the
Eurasia group the political risk
research and consulting firm so at
number three what they call Weapons of
Mass disruption that is technology like
artificial intelligence that can
undermine trust and democracy at number
two maximum
she they say Chinese leader she's
unrivaled power in his own country could
lead to dangerous mistakes and the
number said and the report says the
number one risk is Rogue Russia how it
poses major threats to the United States
Europe and Beyond the president and
founder of Eurasia group Ian Bremer
joins us now to discuss Ian good to see
you good morning so uh let's talk about
this the lat in this time last year the
war between Russia and Ukraine was weeks
away now Rogue Russia you're saying your
report is saying is the number one
threat why hasn't Russia's failure in
the Ukraine war diminished that threat
that it poses no the failure is
increasing the risk because Russia is
becoming the world's most powerful Rogue
State they are diminished dramatically
as a global power Putin couldn't even
show up at the G20 because he was going
to be isolated and embarrassed by all of
these other world leaders but there's no
way for him to back down
um I mean it's not like he can go to the
status said oh my mistake no no NATO's
already expanded Ukraine's much stronger
the Europeans have already cut them off
in terms of gas flows you got to build
those pipelines someplace else it'll
take a decade so any way you look at it
Putin is an incredibly difficult
position but he's got 6 000 news so
what's he going to do if he can't
continue the war in Ukraine he's going
to take it someplace and increasingly
what that means is the war is going to
hit NATO it's going to be asymmetric
attacks like Espionage and uh like cyber
attacks pipeline fiber Russia thinks
that they've been fighting NATO for the
last year NATO has said no no the war is
in Ukraine increasingly it's going to be
hard to keep that in the box that has to
be the top risk that we're facing this
year speaking of that war in Ukraine how
do you anticipate it ending yeah I wish
we could anticipated ending
um you know Ukraine has had the last
year their GDP has has contracted by 40
Russia has only been four percent
Russia's increasingly going to see their
own economy take the kind of hit that
Iran has been taking another smaller
Rogue state in the Middle East for the
last decade
um what that means is that Russia
doesn't have a military that's capable
of continuing to fight and win the war
in Ukraine instead they're going to be
seen by NATO as the principal Danger on
the global stage but that's not an end
to the war right it's an expansion of
the war I mean at least in 2022 we've
all focused on zelenski The Bravery of
44 million Ukrainian people right but
but we've kept the war in Ukraine yeah
in 2023 we're not going to be able to
say that anymore it's not a cold war
with Russia it's really a hot war with
Russia
talking about China I mean the main
tenet of Chinese governance is focusing
on its internal politics and letting
other companies other countries focus on
their own Internal Affairs how do you
think that China especially under Xi
Jinping will
will be a risk to the global
geopolitical landscape if it says that
it's really wants to kind of do its own
thing and let other countries do theirs
the funny thing is the China risk is a
little bit like the Russia risk in the
sense that it centers on one guy that
has extraordinary amounts of power
didn't used to be true in China doesn't
have checks and balances isn't getting
great expertise the way he used to that
allows him to make big mistakes we've
already seen it by Yes Men because he's
surrounded by yes men and because he's
capricious in the decisions that he
makes zero covid which was the win for
China for the last two years suddenly
it's gone and as a consequence China is
like it was in 2020 once again the
epicenter of global covet with no
transparency with the rest of the world
about any new variants that are coming
and how many cases they have and how
many people are dying well what happens
if those sorts of Health decisions get
replicated in economic decisions inside
China National Security citizens inside
China the reason Russia is such a risk
is because Putin made the single biggest
misjudgment of any leader on the global
stage since the Wall came down in 1989.
that's the kind of leadership we're
increasingly seeing in China today but a
lot more powerful China than it was back
in Mao days which the last time you saw
later there was that power so Ian let me
ask you quickly before we go number
seven you have a divided U.S you expect
polarization in the United States to
grow this year and you call the United
States one of the world's most
dysfunctional democracies what are the
geopolitical risks of A Dysfunctional
democracy that is the United States in
your words thankfully they are lower
than a lot of people think this is a
Don't Panic risk the fact that the
United States is at the bottom of the
list even though we're the most powerful
country in the world really tells you
that even when you have leaders that
make big mistakes those mistakes are
constrained people stop them from
happening whether it's the military or
Judiciary or rule of law transparency
all of those things the risks that are
really at the top of this report this
year aging dictators and Tech Bros by
the way increasingly there's some
overlap in those two categories those
are the places where you get have Things
That Go Bump in the night and they
affect all of us when we wake up Ian
Bremer thank you so much it's not just
your knowledge it's your passion as well
we appreciate you good to see you